Musique intense
...
-Journée de 8 heures.
-Démocratie directe.
-Retraite à 60 ans.
-Bourse du travail.
-Syndicat.
-Droit de grève.
-Ecologie.
-Droits des femmes.
-Union libre.
-Avortement.
-Congés payés.
-Sécurité sociale.
-Education populaire.
L'anarchisme,
qui avait montré son vrai visage
au grand soleil d'Espagne,
entre, avec la fin
de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
dans une longue nuit
peuplée de monstres.
Dans l'euphorie de la victoire,
on oublie les pactes,
les passivités
et les collaborations
plus ou moins actives
et on efface les anarchistes
de l'histoire.
Décimés, isolés, oubliés,
incapables de reprendre le combat
sur le front social,
les libertaires choisissent
de s'engager
dans la bataille culturelle.
Ils s'inventent des symboles,
recréent des solidarités
et investissent de nouvelles luttes.
Et dans le cours
de la guerre froide,
ils sont bientôt rejoints
par une jeunesse neuve
qui, tout en donnant de l'anarchisme
une autre image,
contribue à lui offrir
une nouvelle visibilité.
Mais ces nouveaux révoltés
qui rêvent de paix
et prônent l'amour
avec pour seules armes
des fleurs ou des pavés
se heurtent partout au pouvoir.
Et c'est ainsi qu'à l'est
comme à l'ouest et du nord au sud,
l'anarchisme réoccupe petit à petit
le devant de la scène.
Il souffle ses idées depuis
la coulisse du mouvement pacifiste,
il inspire les nouvelles formes
de la contestation
et imprègne enfin,
de son esprit libertaire,
un mouvement insurrectionnel
qui aurait pu...
changer la face du monde.
...
C'est derrière
des fils de fer barbelés,
dans l'odeur âcre du crématoire,
et sous le regard insolent
de maîtres qui croient
qu'ils sont des dieux,
que la seconde partie du 20e siècle
commence aussi
pour les anarchistes.
A Mauthausen,
où comme des dizaines
de milliers
de prisonniers politiques,
les anarchistes
arrêtés par la Gestapo
ou livrés par la police de Vichy,
laissèrent leur peau.
Quand vient la libération,
les antifascistes saluent
en espagnol les forces alliées,
mais les quelques libertaires
qui ont survécu à la guerre
ne peuvent que constater
que le mouvement anarchiste
s'est, en Europe,
réduit comme une peau de chagrin
et qu'il a perdu
presque toute son influence.
Il se replie sur lui-même.
-Après l'échec
de la révolution espagnole,
et au lendemain
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
les anarchistes ne représentent plus
qu'un mouvement minoritaire
qui ne fait que ressasser
ses vieilles idées,
sa mythologie,
en tournant en rond,
sans avoir plus aucune influence
sur les mouvements sociaux.
Alors, effectivement,
on peut dire qu'après l'échec
de la révolution espagnole
et la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
l'anarchisme entre vraiment
dans une longue nuit.
Musique grave
...
-Après la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
il devient très difficile
d'être anarchiste,
que ce soit en Europe,
en Amérique du Nord ou en Asie,
parce que le monde
est divisé en deux camps :
l'est et l'ouest.
-Alors, ce que font les anarchistes,
c'est qu'ils n'optent
ni pour l'un ni pour l'autre.
Ils ne soutiennent
aucun des deux camps
pendant la guerre froide,
et cela les exclut
de la scène politique mondiale.
On se sent très seul
quand on est anarchiste
pendant cette période.
-Au lendemain de la guerre,
les anarchistes ne choisissent
effectivement pas leur camp,
mais ils recréent un peu partout
les organisations.
La Fédération des socialistes
libertaires allemande
et les Fédérations anarchistes
française et italienne
se reforment
dès la fin des combats.
Au nord, l'Organisation centrale
des travailleurs de Suède
devient le bastion libertaire
le plus fort d'Europe,
et au sud, tandis que les exilés
espagnols ouvrent une CNT à Paris,
des groupes de résistance
formés notamment par Quico Sabaté,
qui attaque ici au mortier,
reprennent sur la péninsule
le combat
contre la dictature franquiste.
Même à l'est, on voit renaître
un courant libertaire,
comme en Bulgarie, où la Fédération
des anarcho-communistes
organise son congrès
et rédige une nouvelle plate-forme.
L'Amérique latine
n'est pas en reste,
qui voit les anarchistes
se regrouper,
par exemple au Chili et à Cuba,
au sein des grandes fédérations
syndicalistes révolutionnaires.
Tandis que l'Afrique a perdu
momentanément toutes ses structures,
la toute jeune
Fédération anarchiste japonaise,
emmenée par Ishikawa Sanshiro,
et la Fédération des bâtisseurs
d'une société libre créée en 1945
par les frères Lee Jung-Kyu
et Lee Eul-kyu,
surnommés les Kropotkine coréens,
témoignent
de la survivance de l'anarchisme
en Asie. Mais c'est en dehors
des organisations
et grâce à l'un
de ses courants méconnus
que l'anarchisme,
dans cette longue nuit
de l'après-guerre, commence
à revenir un peu dans la lumière.
-Ce qui se passe pour l'anarchisme,
c'est que l'idée selon laquelle
la guerre serait la santé des Etats,
eh bien cela devient le coeur
de la pensée libertaire
à cause
de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
parce qu'il devient très clair
que l'Etat est directement lié
au fascisme, à la guerre,
aux chaînes de commandement
et aux dommages collatéraux.
-Le pacifisme libertaire
ou anarchisme non violent,
qui vient d'une longue tradition,
connaît avec le début
de la guerre froide
un véritable regain.
Héritiers de La Boétie,
Shelley, Thoreau et Tolstoï,
ses partisans veulent eux aussi
radicalement changer le monde.
Mais ils pensent, à l'inverse
des apôtres de l'insurrection armée,
qu'il est possible et nécessaire
de le faire sans violence.
-C'est un argument
que développent
de nombreux penseurs de premier plan
et qui se fonde
sur l'attention particulière
que les anarchistes accordent
à l'adéquation
entre les moyens et les fins.
Les moyens que vous employez
pour provoquer le changement social
doivent s'accorder avec l'objectif
que vous voulez atteindre.
Si l'on se place dans ce cadre,
le recours à la violence
entre souvent en contradiction
avec vos objectifs.
En effet,
si vous voulez construire
une société
basée sur la coopération,
sur le consensus,
la démocratie directe,
sur la discussion,
alors, la violence politique
n'est pas le moyen à utiliser
pour atteindre ce but.
Il y a même de fortes chances
pour qu'elle nuise à votre projet.
-Ces théories inspirent
d'autant plus les révolutionnaires
à l'époque
que pour la première fois,
la non-violence aurait prouvé
en Inde, dans les faits,
son efficacité.
Mais alors que la guerre froide
s'intensifie,
c'est face à l'émergence
d'une nouvelle menace
à la fois globale et mortelle
que les pacifistes libertaires
peuvent commencer
à se faire connaître et diffuser
plus largement leur pensée.
-Ca change fondamentalement
l'état d'esprit,
non seulement des anarchistes,
mais de toutes les personnes
critiques des pouvoirs établis,
parce que ça marque l'imagination.
L'idée de cette perpétuelle
menace de mort qui plane,
cette bombe qui peut exploser
à tout moment,
ça a poussé les gens
vers les mouvements pacifistes.
La population s'est mise
à demander la paix
de manière passionnée.
-Contre la prolifération atomique,
des mouvements antimilitaristes
et pacifistes éclosent alors
dans le monde entier.
On se souvient en France
du Mouvement pour la paix
et de celui des Citoyens du Monde
de Garry Davis,
mais il y a aussi
le Ban the Bomb Movement
qui s'étend d'Angleterre à Sydney,
et il y aura bientôt
les gigantesques mobilisations
contre la guerre au Vietnam.
Certains sont impulsés
par les libertaires,
comme le Vietnam Day Committee
que fondera Jerry Rubin,
ou le mouvement
pour les objecteurs
de conscience,
animé par Louis Lecoin.
Si presque tous les anarchistes
sont alors pacifistes,
tous les pacifistes ne sont pas
pour autant anarchistes.
On retrouve dans ces mobilisations
des humanistes libéraux,
des chrétiens progressistes,
des socialistes parfois radicaux
et toute une flopée de militants,
sans idées politiques arrêtées,
qui souhaitent juste avoir la paix.
En mettant en oeuvre
une sorte de stratégie du coucou,
les libertaires
n'en décident pas moins
de les rejoindre.
-Ce n'est pas nouveau.
Les anarchistes
de la fin du 19e siècle
faisaient la même chose.
Ils ne créaient pas
d'organisations de masse.
Ils ne poussaient pas les gens
à devenir anarchistes.
Ils essayaient
de radicaliser les gens
afin qu'ils décident
de prendre leurs affaires en main.
Ils diffusaient leurs idées
et les gens s'anarchisaient.
Et les anarchistes de l'après-guerre
font exactement la même chose.
Ils essayent dans ces mouvements
de convaincre les gens
qu'on ne peut pas avoir l'Etat
sans la bombe.
Si vous ne voulez pas de la bombe,
vous devez
vous débarrasser de l'Etat.
C'est l'argument principal
qu'ils mettent en avant.
-Ce qui est vraiment intéressant
à ce sujet,
c'est que
les vieux courants pacifistes
ont commencé
à dénoncer ce lien également,
et grâce à ça,
on a vu naître
des relations très fortes
entre les groupes pacifistes
et les groupes anarchistes.
-C'est au Royaume-Uni,
où, à la différence
des autres pays européens,
le Mouvement pour la paix n'est pas
contrôlé en sous-main par Moscou,
que les liens entre anarchistes
et pacifistes deviennent
les plus solides. Dans la campagne
pour le désarmement nucléaire,
derrière Bertrand Russell,
sa figure de proue,
on retrouve la crème
de l'anarchisme britannique,
comme Herbert Read, Ethel Mannin,
Alex Comfort ou Colin Ward.
Leur influence
se fait rapidement ressentir,
jusque dans le nom
que se donne le mouvement
et qui dit presque tout.
-Le Comité d'action directe
n'était pas seulement
un mouvement contre la guerre.
Il développait aussi
une véritable critique sociale
basée sur les travaux
des anarchistes.
L'emploi du concept d'action directe
en témoigne.
C'est une traduction directe
de la pensée anarchiste.
L'idée,
qui peut paraître en réalité
très radicale
et très conflictuelle,
c'est de changer les choses
vous-même
plutôt que de demander
à quelqu'un d'autre de le faire.
-Au contact des pacifistes,
les anarchistes découvrent
à leur tour
de nouvelles techniques de lutte
qu'ils décident d'adopter
tant elles semblent illustrer
le message libertaire.
-Les tactiques pacifistes,
comme la désobéissance civile
ou les sit-in, par exemple,
mettent en lumière
la violence de l'Etat.
Car en usant de violence
contre des manifestants
non violents,
l'Etat, en quelque sorte,
se condamne lui-même.
-Convaincus
que c'est un mouvement de masse
qui peut leur donner l'avantage,
le 17 septembre 1961,
un appel est lancé
pour une grande manifestation
à Trafalgar Square.
Mis sous la pression,
le pouvoir britannique
réactualise
le Justices of the Peace Act,
une loi vieille de 600 ans,
qui permet d'incarcérer
de manière préventive
les fauteurs de troubles.
32 membres du comité
sont d'ailleurs jetés en prison,
dont Alex Comfort
et Bertrand Russell,
alors âgé de 89 ans.
Le jour dit, pourtant,
près de 15 000 personnes
se rassemblent
et font un sit-in
sur la grande place de Londres.
Là, cette démonstration de force
non violente n'impressionne
que les caméras.
Et déjà,
des anarchistes s'interrogent.
-Beaucoup d'anarchistes
au sein du mouvement
commencent à considérer
les tactiques pacifistes
soit comme très naïves,
soit comme fondamentalement
inefficaces
si l'on pense
à la lutte des classes,
ou même pire, comme une excuse
pour ne rien faire.
-Nombreux sont les révolutionnaires,
au Royaume-Uni comme ailleurs,
à abandonner alors
les tactiques pacifistes, et quand,
par la suite, les anarchistes
accepteront de participer
à des manifestations pour la paix,
ce sera souvent
pour y accroître la conflictualité.
Il faut attendre les années 60
pour qu'au pays des fleurs,
de nouveaux chevaliers blancs
de la révolution mettent,
grâce à une nouvelle forme
de lutte non violente,
à proprement parler
le feu aux poudres.
Musique grave
...
Musique intrigante
Les sixties.
Dans les pays occidentaux,
le monde a bien changé.
Les grands ensembles
ont recouvert
les ruines, le baby-boom
a rajeuni les populations,
le plein emploi
remplit les porte-monnaie
et le rêve américain commençait
à coloniser les imaginaires.
L'émergence d'une classe moyenne
a même fait oublier
l'ancien clivage social.
On est entré dans la société
des loisirs et de la consommation.
C'est le règne des supermarchés,
de l'automobile et de la télé.
C'est l'âge d'or du tabac,
du rock'n'roll
et du soda. C'est aussi
le triomphe de l'Etat-providence
qui impose aux révolutionnaires
d'approfondir leurs critiques.
-Après la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
vous avez un Etat
beaucoup plus présent
qui promeut
une éducation universelle,
qui assure l'aide sociale pour tous,
qui réglemente de plus en plus
les droits des travailleurs.
L'Etat semble donc
plus bienveillant
que les Etats d'il y a
100 ou 150 ans.
Les anarchistes sont donc,
dans une certaine mesure,
le dos au mur,
car la vie semble s'être améliorée
pour beaucoup de gens.
Mais ce que les anarchistes
essaient de montrer,
c'est que cette bonne vie
n'est pas la vie bonne.
-Et l'argument critique
des anarchistes
est que le capitalisme
et la culture de masse
de la société moderne,
vous savez,
le consumérisme,
la publicité,
l'émergence de Coca-Cola,
tout cela incarne
une forme de banalité
et diffuse une sorte
de culture banale et stérile.
-Ce sentiment absurde
est notamment ressenti
par la jeunesse qui a pris
peu à peu conscience de son nombre,
de sa force et du rôle moteur
qu'elle pourrait jouer
dans un processus révolutionnaire.
A l'instar des Etats-Unis d'Amérique
avec le Free Speech Movement,
elle fait entendre sa voix.
En ce début d'année 1965,
ce phénomène va devenir
aussi manifeste aux Pays-Bas,
même si l'anarchisme
n'y a pas encore connu son regain
et que la société
semble verrouillée
de l'intérieur.
-Au début des années 60,
les Pays-Bas
étaient un pays étriqué.
La société était refermée
sur elle-même
et les jeunes n'avaient pas
leur mot à dire.
-Dans les années 60...
...l'autoritarisme ambiant
réfrénait tellement les jeunes
qu'ils n'avaient pas d'autre choix
que de se rebeller.
-C'est un jeune étudiant
en philosophie
qui décide ici
de sonner l'heure de la révolte.
Roel van Duijn a milité
au sein du mouvement Ban the Bomb
et atteint lui aussi les limites
des tactiques de lutte pacifiste.
Mais bien qu'il occupe
une fonction importante
au sein du mensuel anarchiste
De Vrije,
il se sent à l'étroit
dans les organisations libertaires
traditionnelles.
-L'anarchisme des années 60,
c'était en fait
des anarchistes des années 20.
C'était un groupe de vieux,
et lui,
il était le seul jeune,
et il avait du mal
à faire avancer ses nouvelles idées,
ce qui provoquait
des querelles et des disputes.
Il a donc quitté
le mouvement anarchiste très déçu
pour créer son propre mouvement
et son propre magazine.
-Pour lancer son mouvement,
Roel van Duijn décide
avec quelques camarades,
dont l'éditeur Rob Stolk,
de créer un journal.
Ils l'intitulent Provo,
un nom d'autant mieux choisi
qu'en interpellant directement
une partie
de la jeunesse,
qu'ils surnomment "provotariat",
par opposition avec un prolétariat
devenu selon lui incapable
de changer le monde,
il énonce tout un programme.
-Le mot en lui-même était tiré
d'une thèse de criminologie.
Il définissait
une forme de délinquance,
et les provos ont décidé
de l'utiliser de manière créative
pour évoquer la façon dont
on pouvait propager la résistance,
et c'était au travers
de la provocation.
Voilà l'idée.
Donc si vous pouviez transgresser
ou briser les règles,
ou vous engager dans une activité
qui allait choquer ou irriter,
voire faire enrager le pouvoir
et provoquer
une réaction de sa part,
alors vous pourriez attirer des gens
dans un mouvement de résistance.
-Roel van Duijn est bien le premier
à théoriser le fameux cycle
provocation-répression-mobilisation.
Dans un tract,
il en décortique
la mécanique et en affiche
ouvertement les objectifs.
-"La provocation,
dans les circonstances actuelles,
"est devenue notre seule arme
pour démasquer l'autorité.
"Uniformes, bottes, képis, sabres,
"chiens policiers,
gaz lacrymogènes :
"il faut la forcer
à utiliser contre nous
"tous ces moyens de répression.
"Elle sera alors contrainte
de montrer sa vraie nature,
"deviendra
de plus en plus impopulaire
"et l'opinion publique basculera
en faveur de l'anarchie."
-Comme leurs textes
ne sont tirés
qu'à quelques centaines
d'exemplaires,
pour mettre
toutes les chances
de leur côté, les provos
ressortent les épouvantails
et impriment une recette
pour fabriquer des bombes.
-Et cela crée immédiatement
des tensions dans la ville.
Il y a des arrestations,
la presse s'en mêle,
et ça attire les jeunes
qui sont en recherche d'action.
Et donc, ça mobilise,
parce que ça fait exactement
ce que ça avait pour but de faire,
c'est-à-dire provoquer.
-Pour un coup d'essai,
c'est bien un coup de maître.
En quelques mois,
le groupe passe
d'une vingtaine de membres
à plusieurs centaines,
mais s'ils arrivent
à fédérer plus largement,
c'est aussi parce que les provos
ne font pas que provoquer.
Ces partisans de l'action directe
et de la propagande par le fait
font des propositions.
Afin de lutter contre la domination
automobile, par exemple,
ils inventent le plan vélo blanc
et mettent des bicyclettes gratuites
et en libre accès
dans les rues d'Amsterdam.
Ils font des happenings,
manifestent
contre les colonialismes
et imaginent
des alternatives crédibles
à la société de consommation.
A leur mesure
et avec de faibles moyens,
mais toujours sans violence,
les provos essaient donc
de changer le monde en le repeignant
avec cette couleur blanche,
qui devient au coeur des années 60
aux Pays-Bas le nouveau noir
des anarchistes.
Mais le maire d'Amsterdam,
Gijs van Hall,
et Jan Van der Molen,
le chef de la police,
considèrent toute cette agitation
non pas comme de la provocation
mais comme une menace.
Ils empêchent
les happenings
et font confisquer les vélos.
Les provos les inquiètent
d'autant plus qu'en mars 1966,
Amsterdam doit accueillir
un événement
de la plus haute importance.
Or, une fois n'est pas coutume,
les provocateurs
pourraient se sentir provoqués
et décider de passer à l'action.
-A ce moment,
on apprend dans les journaux
que la princesse héritière
venait de se fiancer
avec un Allemand,
un Allemand qui avait été membre
de la jeunesse hitlérienne
et qui avait participé
à la guerre
comme soldat dans la Wehrmacht.
-Il était donc considéré
par la gauche
comme un véritable nazi,
et dans le contexte de l'Holocauste
et la façon dont il s'était déroulé
particulièrement aux Pays-Bas
et à Amsterdam,
c'était vraiment problématique.
-Afin de manifester
leur opposition à cette union
qui aura lieu le 10 mars
et sera retransmise à l'Eurovision,
les provos souhaitent
s'inviter à la noce
et, comme Roel van Duijn
avait théorisé
qu'ils n'étaient qu'une image,
figurer en bonne place
sur la photo de mariage.
Pour faire monter la pression
en amont des noces,
ils s'amusent à faire courir
les plus folles rumeurs.
-Et cette fois encore,
non pas avec de la violence
mais avec des propositions
loufoques.
Ils avaient dit par exemple
qu'ils allaient mettre du LSD
dans l'eau potable d'Amsterdam
ou sur des morceaux de sucre
pour les donner
aux chevaux de la police.
Le LSD était la drogue en vogue
à ce moment-là,
et on l'a d'ailleurs
aussitôt interdite.
Tout cela a créé
une sorte de panique.
-Il y avait donc,
le jour du mariage,
une présence policière massive.
Musique pesante
...
-Au matin du 10 mars 1966,
cette très forte présence policière
a dû dissuader les provos d'agir,
car au début,
tout semble bien se passer.
Le carrosse royal fend la foule
et remonte au pas,
sous l'oeil borgne
des caméras du monde entier,
la place du Dam
vers la Westerkerk.
Malgré le gris du ciel
et du noir et blanc,
pour les millions
de téléspectateurs
qui suivent la cérémonie,
la Hollande
n'a décidément pas usurpé
sa réputation de pays
où il ne se passe jamais rien.
La mariée est bien belle,
le protocole, fastueux,
et l'ordre, assuré.
Mais tout à coup,
c'est la cohue,
le désordre, la confusion.
Le terrorisme
aurait-il frappé
sur le passage
de têtes couronnées ?
Pour la première fois
depuis des dizaines d'années,
des bombes ont explosé.
-Des bombes...
C'était une bombe fumigène.
Il rit.
Juste de la fumée.
-Depuis quelque temps,
les provos
s'étaient préparés.
Pendant des nuits entières,
dans un petit appartement
clandestin,
ils avaient minutieusement mélangé
les trois volumes
de nitrate de potassium
avec les deux volumes de sucre glace
et fabriqué ainsi
plus de 200 bombes fumigènes
qui n'ont besoin
que d'une allumette ou d'un mégot
pour partir en fumée.
Un arsenal inoffensif,
certes,
mais à l'effet de souffle
dévastateur.
-La stratégie était simplement
de perturber l'ordre.
On le fait partir en fumée.
On enfume tout,
c'est de l'enfumage.
Et on ne voit plus,
donc on l'élimine.
C'est évidemment un geste théâtral.
-Ca en a mis un coup
à toute cette pompe
et à tout ce faste,
et les autorités
se sont senties ridiculisées,
ce qui les a mises en colère,
et c'est ce qui explique
pourquoi la répression,
par la suite,
a été si sévère.
-Si le journal Le Télégraphe
n'exige pas vraiment
la solution finale
de la question provo,
le chef de la police demande bien
la tête des meneurs.
La maréchaussée
arpente la ville
avec des mégaphones.
Toute manifestation est interdite.
Tout attroupement
est violemment dispersé.
Dans les rues d'Amsterdam,
la chasse aux provos
est ouverte.
La répression...
frappe.
Musique de tension
...
-Mais une chose
était en train de changer.
La population commençait à avoir
de la sympathie
pour les provos.
On voyait, dans les médias,
que de plus en plus de gens
défendaient leurs actions
et condamnaient
l'attitude des autorités.
L'opinion publique
se retournait
contre la police et l'Etat
en faveur des provos.
-Au milieu de l'année 1966,
malgré la répression,
ou plutôt grâce à elle,
les provos sont
au faîte de leur gloire.
Leur nom résonne,
leurs idées voyagent
et ils font des petits,
aux Pays-Bas,
bien sûr, où des groupes
se constituent à Rotterdam,
La Haye ou Maastricht,
mais aussi dans toute l'Europe,
en Belgique, en Suisse,
en Allemagne de l'Ouest, en Italie,
au Royaume-Uni, à Paris,
où une manifestation
a lieu aux cris
d'"anarchie et liberté".
Et le péril blanc s'étend
jusqu'aux Etats-Unis d'Amérique,
où le Constitution Park de Berkeley
est renommé Provo Park
en hommage
aux révolutionnaires amstellodamois.
Le monde entier
a les yeux tournés
vers la Hollande,
et certains imaginent déjà
que la révolte jeune, ludique
et libertaire des provos
pourrait se transformer
en révolution.
Un mouvement social,
qui va mener
les Pays-Bas
au bord de l'insurrection,
semble leur donner raison.
Le 13 juin,
à l'appel
des organisations syndicales,
une grande mobilisation
des travailleurs
a lieu.
Roel van Duijn et ses camarades
appellent le provotariat
à se joindre à la manifestation.
La mort accidentelle
d'un manifestant,
dont la rumeur dit
qu'il a été victime
de violences policières,
fait converger les luttes.
La manifestation
tourne à l'émeute.
Les provos et les travailleurs,
rejoints
par les étudiants
et les blousons noirs,
transforment le centre-ville
en champ de bataille :
on descelle les pavés,
on retourne les voitures...
Malgré le soutien des proxénètes,
la police
est lapidée,
le journal Le Télégraphe
est incendié,
Amsterdam s'enflamme.
Devant l'ampleur des troubles,
le Parlement est convoqué
en séance extraordinaire.
-Les autorités
étaient mises sous pression,
non pas par les provos
mais par l'opinion publique.
Résultat :
le commissaire de police
a été démis
et le maire d'Amsterdam
a dû démissionner.
-Cela aurait pu être une victoire
pour les provos,
mais pris dans leur logique
non violente
au lieu de pousser leur avantage,
ceux-ci préfèrent
se dissocier du mouvement
en évoquant
une hystérie collective
avec laquelle
ils n'avaient rien à voir.
Incapables de saisir
ce momentum révolutionnaire,
la fin de leur mouvement
n'est plus qu'une longue agonie.
Infiltrés,
leurs plans sont éventés,
et comme les nouvelles autorités
savent ne plus réagir
à leurs provocations,
leur tactique tourne à vide.
Alors, comme ceux
qui vivent du spectacle
périssent souvent par le spectacle,
eux qui n'avaient voulu être
que des images
connaissent le destin des images :
ils deviennent des cartes postales.
-Toute cette attention
internationale
qui venait non seulement
de la presse
mais également de la jeunesse
qui arrivait de partout
- on proposait même
des provotours -,
tout cela dépassait
l'intention originelle
de ces garçons.
C'était juste un club de rebelles,
au départ.
-Dans un dernier sursaut,
Roel van Duijn et ses camarades
décident de dissoudre le mouvement.
Le 15 mai 1967,
ils se réunissent
dans le coin des orateurs
du Vondelpark et annoncent
la fin du mouvement provo.
Propos en néerlandais
...
-Et voilà, c'était la fin.
Après deux ans
pendant lesquels
ils ont mis les Pays-Bas
sens dessus dessous,
les provos sont alors partis
chacun de leur côté.
-Roel van Duijn
confiera plus tard
à propos de l'échec
du mouvement provo :
"Notre seule erreur
est d'avoir visé trop court."
La geste
des provos d'Amsterdam
est aujourd'hui
relativement tombée dans l'oubli
mais aura une influence décisive
dans les années suivantes,
car inspirés par leurs idées
et leurs stratégies
mais aussi conscients
des limites de leur mouvement,
d'autres libertaires vont reprendre
leur flambeau et faire, en 1968,
bourgeonner toutes les espérances
révolutionnaires.
Musique grave
...
-Bonne nuit !
-Faites de beaux rêves !
Thème de "Bonne nuit les petits"
...
-A la veille de l'année 68,
le mouvement anarchiste en France
n'est toujours pas sorti
de la nuit.
Il faut voir que,
fatalité groupusculaire,
ici comme partout ailleurs,
les organisations libertaires
ne cessent, pendant ces années,
de se scinder, fusionner,
disparaître puis renaître.
Pour rassembler tous ces groupes,
coordonner leurs activités
et tisser des liens avec
d'autres cellules révolutionnaires,
on ne trouve pas mieux
que de créer des comités à foison.
On s'y perd.
Face à ces organisations
désorganisées,
il devient essentiel de rétablir
un semblant d'unité.
Le groupe des jeunes libertaires
de Paris
décide d'inventer un symbole.
-L'A cerclé date d'avril 1964.
Il est présenté
devant le mouvement anarchiste
dans un numéro du bulletin
des Jeunesses Libertaires,
des jeunes libertaires,
avec une explication
de pourquoi il serait bon
que les anarchistes,
quand ils font des inscriptions
sur les murs,
quand ils font des affiches,
mettent ce symbole
de façon systématique.
C'est des techniques de marketing,
c'est aussi bête que ça.
Si tous les groupes anarchistes,
malgré leurs différences
très fortes,
et des fois les oppositions
qu'il y avait entre eux,
signaient, mettaient un même logo,
ça aurait un effet multiplicateur
de la présence des anarchistes
sur les murs de Paris
ou dans la vie politique
parisienne.
-L'effet n'est pas immédiat.
Et alors que le vent de contestation
soufflé par la jeunesse
semble charrier,
partout, un esprit
anti-autoritaire et libertaire,
en France, c'est le calme plat.
Un grand journal du soir
prétend même
que la France s'ennuie,
et pourtant,
tout commence
en banlieue parisienne,
dans l'université de Nanterre,
qui est devenue depuis peu
un bouillon de culture
de la contestation
et où l'on compte aussi
de nombreux militants anarchistes
expérimentés.
-Vous appartenez à un mouvement ?
C'est quoi ?
-Oui, c'est un groupe anarchiste,
voilà, et nous publions ces tracts,
qui sont en fait un plagiat
d'un autre plagiat.
La meilleure façon
de savoir ce que c'est,
vous le lisez,
et vous vous ferez votre opinion.
-Vous habitez la résidence ?
-Oui, j'habite la résidence.
Pourquoi ? Vous avez des rapports
avec certains flics, non ?
-Ces militants connaissent
leur histoire libertaire.
Certains sont même allés
aux Pays-Bas
rencontrer les provos.
Ils critiquent
le système éducatif, qui ne fait,
selon eux, que reproduire
les structures de domination.
S'ils veulent porter
la révolution à l'université,
ils entendent plus globalement
changer la vie.
Parmi eux
se fait très tôt remarquer
un certain Daniel Cohn-Bendit,
que l'on dit alors libertaire.
-Il y a pas photo là-dessus.
C'est un militant anarchiste,
membre de la Fédération anarchiste,
membre de la Liaison
des étudiants anarchistes,
membre de Noir et Rouge,
membre de tous ces mouvements,
partie prenante à part entière.
-Mais il n'est pas le seul.
A ses côtés,
d'autres figures apparaissent,
comme Olivier Castro,
qui se définit alors
comme un anarchiste indépendant,
Jean-Pierre Duteuil,
membre de la Liaison
des étudiants anarchistes,
ou le discret René Riesel,
toujours avec ses lunettes noires,
qui fondera le groupe
des Enragés.
Avec une centaine d'étudiants,
ceux-ci décident, le 22 mars 1968,
d'occuper un étage
de la tour administrative
de la faculté de Nanterre.
Ils se regroupent en conseil,
débattent, chantent des chansons
et écrivent sur les murs
les tout premiers A cerclés.
Expulsés de Nanterre,
les étudiants
se rendent à la Sorbonne,
au coeur de la capitale.
La police intervient.
C'est l'étincelle,
car à la différence des provos,
les libertaires parisiens
choisissent,
avec les autres révolutionnaires,
d'assumer la confrontation.
Autour d'Olivier Castro,
que l'on voit ici de dos,
ils organisent la riposte.
Tête casquée, visage masqué,
on ramasse de quoi passer
à l'offensive.
Et pendant plusieurs jours
et plusieurs nuits,
enivrés par l'odeur des gaz,
des révoltés
écrivent dans l'air
une ancienne chanson de geste
ou improvisent
de nouveaux pas de danse.
-Il y a cette griserie
extraordinaire
qui ne prend que les émeutiers.
Qui n'a pas été émeutier
ne peut pas savoir
de quoi il s'agit.
Le goût...
Le goût de la barricade.
Musique grave
-Contrairement
à ce que dit la légende,
la répression est très brutale,
mais rien n'y fait :
le Quartier latin
tombe aux mains des insurgés.
Musique intense
Finalement rouverte,
la Sorbonne est proclamée
commune libre.
Le drapeau noir flotte
sur la cour d'honneur.
On rebaptise les salles
du nom des héros
de l'histoire libertaire.
Une assemblée générale permanente
est formée.
Un comité d'occupation est élu.
On écrit sur les murs.
On réinvente la culture.
On imprime des tracts
et des journaux.
On ouvre une cantine
libre et gratuite pour tous.
On crée une crèche autogérée.
Grâce à la section
des combattants katangais,
on organise aussi l'autodéfense.
A tous les étages,
pendant plus d'un mois,
on discute du monde, de la vie,
de l'amour et de la révolution.
-Il faut changer la société
pour changer l'université.
-Comment faire ?
-En faisant la révolution !
-Tous les étudiants
ne sont pas anarchistes, bien sûr,
mais les libertaires sont là,
avec les militants
des autres tendances
révolutionnaires,
maoïstes, trotskistes,
guévaristes,
avec aussi et surtout
la masse des étudiants
dont les idées
ne sont pas arrêtées,
mais qui veulent prendre part,
eux aussi, au mouvement.
-La grande qualité
des anarchistes de Mai 68
a été de permettre
à une ribambelle de gens,
que l'on appelait "inorganisés"
- des gens qui venaient
de nulle part,
qui soudain émergeaient en mai 68 -,
de prendre toute leur place
et non pas de les renvoyer
à l'école, au cours primaire,
et de les faire passer
tous les échelons.
Ca, ça a été
une grande force libertaire
d'émancipation
qui a permis à chacun
de prendre sa place,
en quelque sorte,
tout en luttant beaucoup
contre les menées staliniennes
de certains groupuscules,
même si c'était pas des staliniens.
Même s'ils étaient antistaliniens,
ils avaient souvent des pratiques...
peu recommandables, disons.
-Le mouvement fait tache d'huile,
et comme ici
avec l'université de Strasbourg,
il s'étend bientôt
à toutes les universités françaises,
mais pas que.
-C'est un moment dans lequel
on a eu souvent tendance
à surévaluer
la composante étudiante,
la composante culturelle
de la contestation,
mais ce qui est très intéressant,
c'est aussi
la composante ouvrière de 1968
et le climat d'insubordination
ouvrière généralisée
que Mai 68 a révélé.
-C'est en effet la spécificité
du 68 français,
car la répression brutale
du mouvement étudiant
avait provoqué
une mobilisation des travailleurs.
Une journée de grève générale
était organisée par les syndicats.
Le 13 mai,
une immense manifestation
avait lieu, drapeaux noirs en tête,
mais le lendemain,
débordant les appareils,
les ouvriers décidaient spontanément
de poursuivre le mouvement.
C'est la 1re grève générale sauvage
de l'histoire.
Musique intense
Tous les secteurs sont touchés :
les grands groupes publics
et les entreprises privées,
des plus grandes aux plus petites.
...
Les centrales sont arrêtées.
Les cheminées ne fument plus.
Dans les mines,
on refuse de descendre.
Les docks sont désertés.
Les secteurs les plus inattendus
entrent dans la grève.
Les banques sont fermées.
Les grands magasins sont occupés
par leur personnel.
Le ramassage des ordures
est suspendu.
Des banderoles décorent
l'entrée des hôtels de luxe.
Les mariniers occupent la Seine.
On ne prélève plus l'impôt.
Les fossoyeurs n'enterrent plus.
Les zoos sont en vacances
et les péages sont gratuits.
La radio et la télévision
réclament la fin de la censure,
et les actualités publiques
remplacent l'amorce de leurs rushes
par des petits A cerclés.
Il n'y a pas jusqu'aux footballeurs,
qui demandent la fin de l'aliénation
et occupent leur fédération.
Lors des grandes grèves de 1936,
on avait compté
2 millions de grévistes.
En mai 1968, il y en a,
au début, 6 millions,
puis, au bout de quelques jours,
plus de 10 millions
dans toute la France.
-Non seulement
dans toutes les grandes villes
de France,
mais aussi dans les campagnes.
Il faut pas l'oublier.
Même moi,
j'ai trouvé dans les archives
des tracteurs qui défoncent
des sous-préfectures.
On n'a jamais vu ça !
-C'était incroyable,
vraiment incroyable.
On n'aurait jamais imaginé ça
une semaine avant.
Cela donne
toute leur justification
aux idées anarchistes.
Les gens sont capables
de prendre conscience.
L'anarchisme, ça se vit.
Les gens sont capables,
s'ils sont conscients,
de le vivre de manière immédiate.
Spontanément,
les gens se transforment
en anarchistes ou en libertaires,
comme s'ils l'avaient toujours été.
-Ces prémices révolutionnaires
laissent de côté
certains aspects
de l'émancipation.
Le patriarcat n'est
que partiellement dénoncé.
Les minorités sont invisibles,
et l'écologie n'est pas abordée,
mais dans les occupations,
l'esprit anti-autoritaire
et libertaire se diffuse à tel point
que vers la fin mai,
on imagine la fin des frontières,
du travail et de l'argent.
-Il y avait des travailleurs
qui occupaient
leur entreprise d'informatique,
comme il y avait
de nombreux autres
lieux de travail occupés.
Ils prenaient un bain de soleil
sur la terrasse de l'entreprise.
La direction est venue
pour leur demander :
"Que voulez-vous ?
"Quelle est votre plate-forme
de revendications ?"
"On ne veut plus travailler.
"On ne veut plus de cette société."
"Oui, d'accord, on comprend,
"mais au niveau
des horaires, du salaire,
"qu'est-ce que vous voulez ?"
C'était un dialogue de sourds.
-C'est comme une chape de plomb
qui explosait,
et les joies de vivre,
les exubérances
ont repris leurs droits.
Quand les exubérances
reprennent leurs droits,
comme Raoul Vaneigem
l'a si bien dit,
eh bien, les gens reprennent
l'envie de vivre,
le goût de vivre
et le goût des audaces.
-Mais ces audaces ne sont pas
du goût de tous.
Dans l'urgence,
le chef de l'Etat convoque
un conseil extraordinaire.
La consigne est répétée
du sommet de l'Etat jusqu'en bas.
-L'opinion du président
de la République, c'est :
"La réforme, oui.
La chienlit, non."
-C'est à Lyon,
où les anarchistes convaincus,
structurés et organisés
sont aux avant-postes
du mouvement,
que la réaction commence.
-Il y a une forte présence
anarchiste à Lyon, c'est vrai.
D'abord, il y a
une tradition anarchiste à Lyon,
qui est ancienne.
Les gens s'inscrivent
dans cette tradition anarchiste.
Les nouveaux anarchistes.
Les anarchistes de Lyon sont tous
des anarchistes new-look
qui ont lu
l'Internationale situationniste
et qui trouvent ça formidable.
-Regroupés au sein
de l'Hydre de Lerne,
un groupe dissident
de la Fédération anarchiste,
ces libertaires new-look
sont nombreux aussi
dans le mouvement
du 22 mars lyonnais.
Ils ont occupé
leur faculté
et tenté de s'allier
avec les ouvriers
des grands bastions
que sont Berliet
et la Rhodiacéta,
mais à la différence de Paris,
le mouvement est, depuis le début,
resté assez sage.
Or, le 24 mai,
emmené par les anarchistes,
le défilé se heurte
à un large dispositif policier.
-Il se passe à Lyon
une seule nuit de barricades,
mais c'est une nuit de barricades
qui est devenue,
en quelque sorte,
emblématique de Mai 68
pour toute la France,
car il se trouve qu'au cours
de cette nuit des barricades,
un commissaire de police est décédé.
-Refluant de la place des Terreaux
sur la presqu'île,
où ils ont mis en déroute
les gardes mobiles,
les manifestants marchent
sur la préfecture de police,
de l'autre côté du Rhône,
mais à l'entrée du pont Lafayette,
un barrage les attend.
Pour forcer le passage,
dans la confusion,
des révolutionnaires
réquisitionnent
un camion de chantier
et le lancent
sur les forces de l'ordre.
-Il est lancé à 5 à l'heure
avec un caillou
sur l'accélérateur,
en première.
Il avance tout doucement,
tout doucement,
et la police a 100 fois
le temps de s'écarter
pour laisser passer le camion.
-La police n'a pas besoin
de s'écarter
puisque le camion dévie lentement
et choque
contre l'un des réverbères du pont,
mais à ce moment précis,
le commissaire Lacroix,
un commissaire de police,
est pris d'un malaise.
-Il est mort
parce qu'il était présent
sur les faits,
la nuit des barricades.
Il est mort de peur.
Il a fait une crise cardiaque
au moment de l'arrivée de ce camion,
mais il n'a pas été touché
par ce camion.
Il a été acheminé
en ambulance
- j'ai trouvé l'archive -
à l'hôpital Grange Blanche,
et il a été soigné à cet hôpital.
Il était vivant.
Il a parlé avec les médecins
et les infirmiers.
Et puis, au cours du traitement,
une heure ou deux après,
il est décédé
au cours du traitement.
Voilà. Donc, il n'est pas décédé
écrasé par le camion.
-Eh bien, messieurs,
jusqu'à ces jours-ci...
-Pourtant, le lendemain,
aux premières heures du jour,
le préfet de police de Lyon donne,
en direct à la télévision,
une autre version des faits.
-C'est ainsi
que le commissaire René Lacroix,
père de trois enfants,
fut écrasé
entre le parapet du pont
et ce camion.
-Le but était
de criminaliser tout 68.
Effectivement,
du fait
qu'un commissaire de police
est décédé,
la réaction s'est emparée
de cet événement
pour en faire le cri de ralliement
de la vengeance.
-Stratégie du choc
et fabrique du consentement.
Au cours des funérailles nationales
du commissaire,
on répète à l'envi
la version policière.
*-Le commissaire Lacroix
fut écrasé entre le camion
et la rambarde du pont.
-Cet événement souvent négligé
de l'histoire de mai contribue,
avec d'autres,
à faire qu'en quelques jours,
l'opinion publique se retourne
et la situation se renverse :
le pouvoir reprend l'avantage.
Les manifestations sont interdites,
les lieux occupés sont évacués
et des militants
sont incarcérés
ou, comme Daniel Cohn-Bendit,
expulsés.
Mai 68 a vécu.
Mais si la révolution libertaire
est manquée,
grâce à la lutte,
les travailleurs obtiennent
de meilleures conditions
de travail et de vie.
Les lycées et les universités
se démocratisent,
et la censure dans les médias
recule momentanément.
Le rapport de force
né du mouvement
permet de conquérir plus tard
certains de ces droits
que les anarchistes réclamaient
depuis des décennies,
comme celui à l'avortement,
confirmant en cela
le vieil adage libertaire
selon lequel
aucune tentative révolutionnaire
n'est jamais vaine.
-La guerre d'Espagne,
Mai 68,
sont effectivement des échecs,
mais les gens s'en souviennent
comme d'un moment
où il a été possible
de renverser le régime.
Cette impression perdure.
La remise en question
des hiérarchies
a été très profonde.
Jusqu'à aujourd'hui,
rien n'a pu l'effacer.
Musique grave
...
-Stoppé en France,
le mouvement insurrectionnel
se poursuit dans le monde.
Du nord au sud,
d'une rive à l'autre des océans,
quels que soient les régimes,
après Mai, la fièvre émeutière
s'empare
de toutes les grandes capitales
avec comme consigne
de faire comme en France.
A Bruxelles, Londres,
Zurich, Stockholm,
Montevideo ou Tokyo,
les étudiants
occupent leurs universités,
créent des communes
et appellent
les travailleurs
à les rejoindre.
Pensant profiter
de leur gloire retrouvée,
et saisir l'esprit de la révolte,
les anarchistes organisent,
en septembre 1968,
à Carrare, en Italie,
un nouveau congrès international.
On annonce un grand moment
de confrontation et de vérification,
et la presse, venue en nombre,
doit donner de l'écho à l'événement.
Les figures du mouvement
montent chacune leur tour
à la tribune,
mais les vieux démons
ressurgissent :
les générations s'opposent
et les courants se déchirent.
Au moment où les organisations
anarchistes auraient pu peser
dans ce mouvement révolutionnaire
international,
elles ratent
le train de l'histoire.
La réaction qui partout opère
étouffe dans les urnes
ou noie dans le sang les rêves
de changement de la jeunesse.
La marche des étudiants
contre la guerre
est écrasée à Chicago.
Au Japon, on expurge
la forteresse
des étudiants révolutionnaires
de l'université Todai.
Le 2 octobre 1968,
sur la place des Trois Cultures,
au Mexique,
le gouvernement fait tirer
sur les étudiants
qui s'étaient
pacifiquement rassemblés.
Il y a plus de 300 morts.
Cet événement, qui restera
dans les mémoires comme le massacre
de Tlatelolco
et vient mettre un terme au rêve
d'un possible changement pacifique,
rappelle les mots de Bakounine
à de nombreux révolutionnaires.
-"Les révolutions ne sont pas
un jeu d'enfant
"ni une joute littéraire
où l'on ne verse que de l'encre.
"La révolution, c'est la guerre.
"La guerre détruit
les hommes et les choses.
"L'humanité n'a hélas
pas encore inventé
"un moyen plus pacifique de progrès,
"mais jusqu'ici,
tout pas nouveau ne s'est fait
"qu'après avoir reçu
le baptême du sang."
-CAR NOTRE SANG BLEU EST NOIR
NOTRE DRAPEAU ROUGE EST NOIR
NOTRE ETOILE JAUNE EST NOIRE
NOTRE VIE EN ROSE EST NOIRE
OUI NOTRE SANG BLEU EST NOIR
NOTRE DRAPEAU ROUGE EST NOIR
NOTRE ETOILE JAUNE EST NOIRE
NOTRE VIE EN ROSE EST NOIRE
"Black bloc", Achab
...
BLACK
ET ON FAIT BLOC
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA